we're just seven months away from the
midterm elections according to multiple
polls republicans are now poised to take
back the house hopefully the senate also
which will be a little harder but as
i've said many times i take nothing for
granted when it comes to elections the
only way to send a message to biden and
pelosi and schumer and kamala harris and
the uh religious climate alarmist cult
and the new green deal socialist
democrats is to vote everyone in america
you will all play
a key role it's all hands on deck we're
all spokes in a wheel on election day
and by the way uh take a look that's why
it's so troubling to nancy pelosi
we have every intention of winning it is
absolutely essential for our democracy
that we win i fear for our democracy and
the republicans forever to get the gavel
we can't let that happen democracy is on
the ballot in november
the republic hangs in the balance and i
don't think nancy's so worried about
democracy as she is about her own job
here with more house minority leader
kevin mccarthy okay i can't name a
single thing joe biden has done that i
could say you know what i agree with
that he's he's helped the american
people can you
no all he's ever done is make every
crisis even worse and what's worse sean
is look at the budget that he just
produced you know they say the budget is
about their values never once in this
president's budget does he mention the
inflation crisis the border crisis the
debt crisis nor does he mention parents
but you know he mentions the climate
crisis 33 times he mentions tax fee
penalties
120 times it just shows really where
their values are how unserious they are
but what's worse about this budget where
he's talking about gasoline price so
high he taxes 45 billion dollars in tax
for anybody doing energy production so
what does that mean america gets
punished your gasoline prices go higher
and our enemies around the world that
produce oil and gas are going to make
taxpayers money pay for that the one
thing that is very consistent that i
hear from
listeners on my radio show and it's from
all over the country and i'm on 675
stations i get i get a a wide variety of
people from all over the country and
they're all saying the same thing they
want republicans to fight
i want you to assure them that if they
elect the republicans and you became
speaker how hard are you guys going to
fight and how committed will you be to
promises you make that's what i hear
from everybody
we're more than 100 percent sean what we
just came off of and newt gingrich was
there we just did our retreat in florida
building our commitment to america where
the parents have a bill of rights where
the border will be secure where america
will be energy independent not just
energy independent but dominant we will
curve the inflation that the democrats
have brought forward balance our budget
to be able to move forward not only is
just a commitment hold our feet to the
fire we're making this pledge to every
single person across america we believe
that you should know what we will do if
you entrust us with the majority and
we're looking at things even differently
we've spent time at mit for the last
couple days why
because we're looking how we can make
sure america is americans next century
that we can compete with china as well
our focus is on american jobs american
security and american prosperity
will americans be able to stop
this
record high budget proposal that would
even tax unrealized gains in other words
money you don't even have money didn't
even make just estimates what we think
they'll make will republicans stop this
the
biggest budget in the history of this
country with the biggest deficit in the
history of the country
yes we can stop it but we also need your
help i need everybody you just watched
nancy pelosi sit there and cry that if
republicans take the majority that
democracy will end
all she cares about is power the
democrats very first bill was to change
election law so they stayed in power i
need everyone who listens to you who
watch you to go to firepelosi.com
join with us so we can turn america in
the direction that you all crave that we
have secure borders energy independent
that we will curb this inflation that we
will build more jobs and parents will
have a say in their kids education
donald trump showed the republican party
how to fight i hope every republican on
the ballot is willing to fight and for
the principles make america great again
america first reagan conservatism it
works we were a lot better off uh kevin
mccarthy thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else